[Music]
in the sky
I've been feeling it all day I wanna let
it go
I wanna lose none
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I just adore our act I said I can live
run toes to the lovers and so see you
doing night do you good morning
Millennials happy Friday welcome back to
the morning toast it is a bright and
sunny glorious day here in New York
because everyone knows even God that
it's Friday that it's Friday that the
traffic is winding down in New York we
made it through this week and it just it
couldn't be a better Friday feel and I'm
by diplomats I was actually gonna post
that on my story by diplomat I think one
of them lives in my building
that's pretty actually just who live in
my building I actually feel as though
with I word diplomat I might live in my
building cuz it's like it's good
proximity yeah yeah maybe they do I have
to get the doorman it's good scoop
doorman in New York hold the secrets to
the world yeah since I've been
traversing the city and just walking
everywhere I feel like I've seen a good
amount of like Secret Service people who
wear the pins but I don't think I've
spotted any diplomats in the wild so
I've seen like more than usual amounts
of like Suburbans and Escalades which is
how you know like bigwigs are in town
totally do you think for the diplomats
like at UN week that it's kind of like
the Olympics like the Olympic Village
like they're just having lots of sex
no they're definitely it's like a big
mixer well I feel like it is I drove
past the Nigerian embassy cuz it sound
like 42nd and second and it was poppin
like so many people outside inside
walking around like it was so much
security
they had guardrails like it was crazy I
feel like there are so many embassy
parties and I don't know if I was like
coming in from just a small country who
wasn't involved in drama like I would
come to you and week like see my fellow
diplomats like maybe make a couple show
yeah like that's a meet-cute but is that
considered like traitorous it's truth
it's treason
yeah somebody think about that is okay
what if you're like the assistant we did
Matt hooking up with a fellow and say do
you have like no steak I think it's fun
there so or like a Secret Service okay
with it fellow Secret Service I don't
know I just think it could be like a
really cute hallmark movie oh god it all
comes back to hold on I didn't Arnie
United in our hearts United in the sack
oh yeah oh my god I have to tell you the
craziest thing so been yesterday I left
the house at 8:30 keep him at the time
actually is a crazy story he left the
house at 8:30 to go record to ship it's
usually takes like an hour hour and a
half sometimes they get drinks
afterwards so at 10 o'clock he was on
the way home and I said can you pick me
up a fountain soda so at 10 o'clock
exactly he calls me from the bodegas
like they don't have fountain soda I'm
like okay just forget it come home so he
was on the corner of my apartment at 10
o'clock and you know I'm facetiming you
I'm watching TV and times rolling by
eyeshade some food and I look at my
clock it's 10:45 and I'm like holy [ __ ]
like where has been bid for the last 45
minutes and I checked this location and
it wasn't picking it up and I called his
phone and his phone was off so obviously
my mind always goes morbid he was hit by
a car okay and I'm like kind of freaking
out he's hiding me and I was like no he
definitely just doesn't wanna come home
empty-handed and he's going to get you a
soda like he will find you a soda I wish
okay yeah I knew that wasn't the case I
get it I got it so not bettin like I
really miss or one small thing and like
all it takes is just to go across but
he's good now he's like on a hunt for
the soda no trust me that's so not who I
was just trying to keep spirits alive so
I'm like just really freaking out like
trying not to get so anxious and I'm on
the phone with Jackie I'm on the toilet
and the doorbell rings and I'm like oh
it's been so hung up open the door and
he's like sofa Clem's he's like I was
mugged and I'm like Liberty like my
heart ache I'm like what are you okay
like mugging like someone comes up to me
they could punch you like give me your
money like Cher and clueless like yeah
with a gun good thing I wasn't wearing
an Alaia yeah so I'm like in a water
really important design so he comes in
the house and he said yeah like I was
walking home from the bodega and I
realized my wallets gone and I'm like
they snuck in he was like well I don't
know I'm like why like that's hot muggy
he's like someone took it on my pants
like while I wasn't looking and I'm like
so you were pickpocketed he's like yeah
I'm gonna make jokes a muggy and then
I'm like wait no
when were you pickpocket is cuz he
bought himself a bottled water at the
bodega so he's claiming that between the
bodega and my apartment
literally less than a block he was
pickpocketed okay so he went back to the
bodega almost like looking all over for
it I'm like baby someone found it in the
bodega I took it like you didn't get
pickpocketed like he that's so classic
bed like to deflect you know right that
is so confusing so he left he probably
left it in the bodega and someone
snatched yeah it's true you could not
leave anything hanging around
interesting but like the way that he
came in like this all sweaty his hair a
mask like I was mugged I was like you
know you live in New York and like it's
very common but none of us think I'm not
gonna what have ever experienced Benny
Smollett oh my god that's [ __ ]
hilarious that's what it was like it was
totally fake like I left shocked but you
know I'm actually surprised like none of
us like think I've ever really
encountered a mugging like it's so
common in at work I'm Jevon Ben said it
was so believable but so unbelievable
yeah that my heart like sink I was like
oh my god he needs to start carrying a
murse he's such a drummer
he needs a little purse or up Danny pack
there's some really cool men's Fanny's
on the market right now um he knows miss
for him or he needs a little briefcase
we tried to think what I can just see
the way his pocket I don't know if he
was pickpocketed but like a lot of guys
they just wear theirs they're small
jeans and their big wallet in their back
pocket he was wearing baggy sweatpants I
know he's a victim and we're saying what
was he wearing
but like I just feel as though a murse
is very an underrated thing it would be
pick pickpocket it yeah but it sounds
like he left it in the bodega more
lovely course he did it was just so
dramatic for literally no reason like
getting my spirits all tangled yeah when
nothing was wrong and I think I'm he
wasn't with you but again he wasn't
mugged so nobody was totally thought
Theo would have been fine
Theo would have taken care of it house -
yeah we need to talk about some answer
like I'm a Theo because he is just
getting more beautiful by the more
precious and more perfect and like I
feel like there that can't be that can't
be right he's almost like evolving at
such a rapid pace ed it's like it's it's
beyond Darwin's expectation check his
DNA I know yeah turns out he's a hundred
percent in that [ __ ] literally
send that kid totally cuties also
something funny and that I wanted to
share with the toasters now that we're
talking about like Mason whatever we
tried to make Murch mace cuz like we
thought it'd be like we didn't try we
had like an idea out there in a grain
store and everyone was like it's like
fully illegal like you can't even buy it
in New York like people I know their
parents get it for them in New Jersey
yeah so there won't be any merch nice
coming soon but no post email coming
soon stay tuned gird your loins because
it's the good stuff it's the best stuff
yeah whoo well you're going away this
weekend we're gonna miss you yes I'm
going to Malibu for a retreat with vital
proteins and it's like so far for a
weekend but they told me Lauren
Elizabeth there's nothing so I'm like
okay I'll go but Malibu was just like so
beautiful about it it's like the chicest
trip ever it's I got no booze so it like
assignment proteins is so premium no
premium I'm actually really excited
you're really good no I'm really excited
and you know what it's like
it's devoted to relaxing like there's
facials like I'm really I don't even
think I'm gonna have a drink like I'm
really looking forward to detox a famous
laughs yeah maybe like Saturday you know
Friday night like you'll be at Nobu and
like be like cheering Shaughnessy oh
when are you putting me for my show you
just quoted my one-woman show tickets
available job calm I'm coming to San
Diego San Francisco and Los Angeles next
week
whoo I wonder if now that the Smasher
has been to every show like if she knows
your whole set backwards and forwards
you could be her understudy I literally
could be let's say I got sick you go you
come onstage what's the first thing you
say she says and then and then well I'm
so having a beer you know I sing chosen
that does best one yeah but you're like
make my shows how that stupid it's not
no it's not no it's not oh my that's
hilarious what do i how do I end well
before that look at my last words thank
you very good very good she's paying
attention this is funny well Snatcher
and i will be here this weekend Snatcher
I'm happy for you know that I am yeah so
I gotta head to the airport so we got a
chick Chuck oh yeah everyone let's make
sure today and I just want to say that
it is from one
our sponsor she dazzle look you like are
on that ShoeDazzle grind and you wanted
to get it isn't it cute very cute I like
with a test for my bust it's not an ad
it's not mad but just a helping hand
so I think a thing I think given your
flight time yeah and given the time it's
time it's time it's time it's time for
the fast drive story is that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast and that's
true it's definitely true but and I'm
gonna let you finish but I wouldn't let
everyone know that today's episode is
brought to you by one of our newer and
one of my favorite sponsors or eight
it's insanely good quality jewelry
company or eats gold feels substantial
and the diamonds sparkle and shine
they're very high quality and super
beautiful they're made here in New York
it's all real gold you can wear it and
never take it off shout I hate getting
jewelry that like you have to take off
in the shower like that's how you know
it's some type of jeweler you should
wear where you go green oh my god that's
actually the worst no doesn't happen
with orate all their pieces come with a
lifetime warranty because they know that
it'll last because they sell directly to
you without the middleman they can offer
real same quality as traditional fifth
avenue brands at a fraction of the cost
and the best part is that for every
piece sold to child in need receives a
book to further their education it's
fine jewelry made in New York founded by
women for women
prices range pieces range from classic
to statement to completely original or
it makes the jeweler you've always
wanted but could never find they're
looking to set the standard for women
because they deserve the best that is so
true we do deserve with us it's so true
I've been up being my jewelry game with
orate recently I've gotten so many
compliments and I'm just loving this
brand YouTube for 15% off your first or
a purchase go to or a new york.com slash
toast and use the promo code toast so
again that's or eight New York a you are
a te new york.com slash toast and use
the promo code toast if you want to just
be as premium as us totally and that's
pretty premium pretty premium it is
that's pretty cool yeah ready for ready
for the news of the day we're different
yeah the the first story is probably the
biggest news of the day which is the
biggest news that j.lo and chow era are
joining forces for Superbowl halftime
performance you guys we were speculating
about this on the show on Monday
was almost certain that it was gonna be
j.lo this shakira is a fun twist yes
it's a little zest I saw a very funny
tweet that really summed up how I'm
feeling about this like really excited
as long as she cured us and sings
she-wolf
know what I feel the same I hope she
does sing um she's thinking that would
be a good time to showcase my Shakira
impression it's like the one impression
I actually do very very well very yeah
it's what I do very well at you haven't
done in a while I'm a little nervous I
got used to do at camp all the time with
people like wow you're amazing but now
that I feel like I'm a comedian like I'm
surrounded by people who are like are
actually trained and doing impressions
like it's not very good but whatever
nobody it's good so here we go preview
of the Superbowl 2020 halftime show
featuring all better when you talk like
that
you'll make a woman gone bad so be wise
and keep on leading signs in the body
I'm starting to get excited pretty good
we're lament too big to get there and I
haven't heard her sing in so long like
no oh she's gonna drop some new box
ahead of the Super Bowl also that song
is really good wherever whenever yeah
but that's I think that's what launched
or whatever you know it sounds really
good - it's really good - waka waka come
in um nah let's go back actually you
know what I think what is she she's got
no way
there's this old interview of JLo that's
going right before I just before I
tangent I want to talk about the Super
Bowl and just say like justice for mr.
305 I do believe he might be the third
feature still because we are in Miami
he's mr. 305 like he's actually mr.
worldwide also but like he got his Oh -
yeah but technically he could do any
Super Bowl because he is mr. worldwide
and also he could do the Olympics
because he is mr. worldwide oh that's
true but he's also this
yes and I got started and like the area
code for the Super Bowl hotline will be
305 and you know who else could have
been like applicable not as like a star
but maybe as an add-on his dj khaled yes
you were saying that and I was actually
know saying that and I feel as though
with JLo Shakira like I think dj khaled
that would actually be like better no I
don't think he would be better alone he
would make it better yeah yeah he would
be like a great third yeah like bringing
another element actually but so when mr.
305 and he has that 305 so we need mr.
305 Ali but like I'm over into hippo on
JLo song yes yes I wanna dance the best
one that hurts you one of her best songs
from like with the New Age yeah
JLo still like let's get loud is the
song that makes me just like literally
want to take my top off and just like
shake which of these really I go to a
bat mitzvah and she's been putting on
music I don't know I kind of like dinero
these days meet you by the way when I
went when I had my bump it's a meeting
like with Debbie the party planner and
they were like what songs you want to
play I literally the only song I said
let's get loud by JLo like that was my
[ __ ] jam it's such an it like that
song will never not make me lose my
goddamn mind and they don't play it
enough at like clubs and you know like
it's - I'm getting so excited for the
show
me too I wasn't excited honestly before
but now I am me neither we got to go
through the hits what other songs does
JLo had evacuate the dancefloor Chuckie
no that's cascade oh yeah it sounds like
a JLo yeah it could be
uh-oh she has Oh ain't show mama huh
jayven Bach Oh totally Oh Dubois it you
get my beep on the night side okay right
we learn to dance to that summer that's
Fat Joe do you remember when we learned
to dance
Oh course for time there are certain
songs that I can't listen to without the
thinking of dance classes at sport I'm
like crazy and love of course and
there's a part in that song where the
dance move is like this
I remember the dance teacher used to be
like get out of my way get out of my way
kick-ball-change like she would say that
yeah so when I hear that song it's like
get out of my way get out of my way oh I
remember we used to do like a watered
down version of what she did in the
video where we were just like stomping
and I felt pretty cool
oh so another song I'm real I'm real the
way yeah also love don't cost a thing
oh that's it Wow - any Selena that would
be so excited some dreaming of you
tonight whoever doesn't like us singing
out the podcast like it's gonna [ __ ]
hit sub said yeah we should put it in
the title yeah they were singing when we
were we seeing JLo and Shakira hits oh
my god I just
I actually am getting very excited I'm
getting so excited but now I'm nervous
because she can only perform so many
hits and and she's also splitting it
with Shakira so it's even less and I
hope she goes like into into the
archives you know yeah waiting for
tonight just hast it has to be has to be
and let's get loud and then I'll be
happy and now it's making me not want to
go to the Super Bowl because having been
to the Super Bowl I know that the
halftime show is very much made for TV
like we didn't Justin Timberlake's
microphone like was not even on and his
back was towards us the whole time so I
kind of want to watch it like on today I
know so much like such a better
experience do you think I want to go to
the Super Bowl
me too like if we could stand some
tickets I guess it'll depend on who's in
the bowl yeah I mean here's who I want
to be in the bowl look I am a Dallas
Cowboys Stan so Dallas Cowboys and I
really just want good things for Sierra
and I think her husband is still on
Seattle Seahawks
so then oh that that would actually be a
great game right guys the Seahawks
versus the Cowboys with is that possible
or are they in the same conference it's
not possible oh they're on the same side
yeah
it's Russell Wilson still on the Seattle
Seahawks oh he's playing very well good
I'm still happy for Sierra and Andy
Cohen had her on watch out inside and
apparently he just signed a contract
that's like well it's a start it's like
the most money anyone's ever made the
Superbowl and any was asking her so many
questions about like our newfound money
and she like was being so coy about it
shows being like so classy
yeah she's such a [ __ ] class act I
wanted to talk about what you have
inside because I watched last night the
episode with Stephanie Holman and Anna
Dorfman and I just think as watch what
happened five episodes ago it was a
great episode chemistry between the
guests both giving great answers and
Stephanie on the show peejoe all the way
he drove but Andi Dorfman and watch what
happens live was a star what do you mean
by that
star beautiful well-spoken smart funny
gave T what didn't throw it to my
apartment like some they asked like say
through things nice things about Josh
Murray like she couldn't they asked her
if if it's true that mike johnson was
about to be the bachelor and then they
picked peter and she was like i actually
have it on very real authority that that
is not true everyone says that yeah they
asked her colton said that he felt
pressured to not show how much he liked
cassie during his season and and he was
like you get that pressure but only from
yourself not producers because i don't
want to be show that you're in love with
someone and then go on the date with
someone else yes she just had like great
answers for everything and and he said
the funniest story in the beginning he
was like we had to go and andy cohen
very question Andy Cohen was like when
he was introducing her onto the show he
was like we actually ran into each other
in the West Village earlier this week
and he was like he ran up to me and you
were like I'm coming on your show this
week and he was like sure and then he
realized oh my god and it's just so
funny I think he was so impressed by her
and then he was so shocked that she's
single and now I think he wants to set
her up oh my god that she would come
fresh with him I'm gonna be so why did
he jealous that's her up with John
they're just something to think about I
just I was really I mostly like if it
can't be me like it should be her
because she's she really is like that I
like I really like her but it should be
me she and I feel like she was just so
well-spoken and a number after she was
impressive and she was an impressive
Bachelorette but this is a whole new
format also I think it's interesting
which Bachelor people have got on watch
what happens live and the only other
person I know of is Nick Dyle
oh yeah when he right after he was the
bachelor they had him on um but they
don't really have that sure people on
their show well also it's a technical
competitor because it's ABC so they
don't like turned out like they do Bravo
and II sense but like I do think it's
interesting too I think that bachelor
stars are becoming more and more of a
celebrity than they were ever before so
if there's ever a time for them to go on
watch ovens live and things like that
it'll be now yeah like I could see
Hannah Brown going on but like I don't
think she will yeah I just can't see at
her in Andy Cohen was really vibe yeah
nobody there but you know what speaking
of the Hannah brown and Jen's were the
stars
gilina at lane class tonight because I
haven't spoken to him so long and she
was like so tired she's like dancing all
the time every day all the time like
it's all she ever does and she's loving
life so we gotta vote for her we need to
keep her on because me and Jackie need
to go to a dance sorry we all need to go
- yeah you're - in episode and she's to
still be on so we're gonna be in LA for
my show October 13th tickets available
at roville job Turk I'm sorry October
12th and I want to go the next day so we
need to make sure she's still on all the
trousers need to vote for her
yeah um cuz we're and then we're doing
our show from LA was just gonna be LA we
rate guess so my show in LA is at the
Ace Theatre on Sunday tickets available
Carlton job to come and then that week
Monday through Thursday we are doing
episodes not live because we don't have
the capability but podcasts and video
episodes with for premium guests I
believe two of them are confirmed but I
don't want to like say it until you
happens you know like everything that
was happening so yeah for a premium
guests and then Friday I'm heading to
San Diego for my show they are so
tickets available girl [ __ ] huh
exciting stuff okay some more exciting
news Bravo news from Beverly Hills to
Broadway Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills
Erika Jayne to play Roxie Hart in
Chicago the musical this is a crazy
story just because like good for her but
it's even crazier because what like two
months ago it was like fake news
reported that LuAnn de Lesseps was doing
this and then it came out to be not true
they had like a scheduling conflict or
that it was like never really happening
like it was just a fake rumor yeah but
this one is not Erika Girardi is heading
to the Great White Way the real house
has a Beverly Hills star will be making
her Broadway debut this January starring
as a murderous housewife an aspiring
nightclub singer Roxie Hart in the
tony-winning revival of Chicago the
musical Girardi who has had an
illustrious recording career under the
station Erika Jayne will begin
performances on January 6 2020 her
12-week limited engagement run wraps up
on March 29th and we have to see her
she's just the type of person who like
um like good things keep happening for
her in her business because I think she
took genuinely like a nice good person I
think she's like nice to everyone that
she works with but something that's
interesting that I was thinking about
yesterday do you agree with me that
she's really going by Erika Girardi like
a lot less these days like less than
ever
yes but I think it's because the bigger
she becomes like as a public persona
she's Erika Jayne like she's only air
could you RT like in her personal life
and she doesn't why do you think she
does is Erica change like ever have an
implication on like her husband's
serious business it's like the bigger
she gets that means the bigger Erica
Jane gets and Erika Girardi is like this
constant but Erika Girardi doesn't do
like appearances right so Erika Jayne
will only get bigger and then she's just
heathered to miss Girardi yeah you know
I mean she's like it's her staging so
she keeps getting on the stage
opportunity right he's gonna go by her
stage name yeah and that's why I think
it's actually really smart for her to
separate the two it's really smart he's
like Hannah Montana before her right and
it's like I felt like and so it she can
go to school at me in hormone caramel
right with like Thomas like a serious
star it's like a serious business man
and like she never wants like something
like she does or says so I get back to
Tom you know yeah even though I mean
they're twine like to have like a bad
like like implications for him you know
yeah totally know she has a great thing
going on this is just another step
towards mega stardom for her and I'm so
happy for her I'm so excited this is
really prestigious you know you know
what it is but it's also an interesting
time because this happens with a few
housewives where the show makes them
bigger larger than life bigger than the
show nene leakes going on Glee like she
knew I was watching Glee last night
that's why I was thinking about I was
actually thinking about that tweet you
posted about mr. Shue oh that was funny
hilarious and then I was just thinking
about our episode with mega Tobin where
you gettin dropped across Washington and
I don't know why it makes me laugh so
much because Roz Washington nene leakes
ugly was not only one of the most
amazing things to ever happen for the
Housewives franchise but it was one of
the best roles that Glee ever created
that's why yeah but it's an interesting
folk-like moment where very few
housewives like the show catapults them
to such success beyond the Housewives
franchise and what they do with it is
really interesting like NeNe Leakes I
think really handled it poorly like I
think she became like snobby and thought
she was too good for the show and then
like moved to LA and made the ladies
come and that whole season was really
weird and now she's kind of been humbled
and it's back to being like a full-time
cast mate it happens with Bethenny like
I think Bethenny will say because now
she has orbited past the show like no
but she already orbited past one she
ever and she's totally bailed she
and she came back like with her tail
between her legs now I think she because
it's happened twice and nobody gets this
chance twice
nobody gets orbited like to major
success twice but now Bethenny she's on
shark tank she has the relief effort
it's like she has evolved past the show
like what does she them to do with it
now the world might never know
oh I think now she's cemented in her in
her fame and in her like wealth and
businesses and I mean I guess maybe her
businesses would maybe suffer if she's
not on the show but I don't really think
so no the problem was good I'm learning
Skinnygirl popcorn every week we are dis
of whether she's on my TV or not so I'll
just be interested to see how I retain a
handle say because there were a lot of
talks about her leaving the show this
season none of them were founded but
it's like a conversation being had so I
just wonder if at any point she's gonna
feel like the show was actually holding
her back you know I don't think so
because when I read her book she has so
much like gratitude and understanding
for like this show and and how it
launched her that I think she will
always appreciate that platform I hope
so
I do and I don't think that being on
Broadway for two months is gonna change
that
I mean either she said she's but she's a
smart woman yes she truly is learning
from those who came before her next
story Gwyneth Paltrow just roasted her
kids on national TV and called them
dicks this party is so funny it was on
to the Today Show with Savannah Guthrie
and she explained that the two kids that
she shares with her ex Chris Martin 15
year old Apple and 13-year old Moses are
old enough to talk and formulate deep
thoughts about different subjects which
gets interesting she said quote they're
really coming into themselves they're
hilarious they're smart they can talk
they can sort of muse about things it's
the greatest yeah they can kind of be
you know dicks once in a while that's
open e that reminds me of brandy on Real
Housewives of Dallas right now and I've
been a bit mom shamed for the way that
she's parenting her daughter and also
the way her daughter's talking back to
her and also the way that she's talking
about her daughter when I think she
called her like a little [ __ ] or
something yeah um I mean I'm not a mom
so I'm not gonna you know put my stake
in the ground here but I feel like this
is like it's funny funny like come on if
someone can't see the humor and someone
calling their kid a [ __ ] you're a dick
like I cannot with you I mean honestly
I'll take a dump on my far head and I
would say that it was art like I care I
love her so much like I downloaded the
politician for my flight I'm so [ __ ]
daddy tonight weekend yeah there's so
many you know what I could talk about
this for hours like so many things I
love about Gwyneth Paltrow like one
Country Strong - I happen to believe she
is literally the most beautiful woman in
the world like and she looks just as
beautiful now as she did when she was 19
like I just I said also like her
relationship with Brad Falchuk because
they met ugly it's just like so super
special to me and the fact that like he
wrote the politician like and he wrote
this role for her yeah he's so special
I'm like you know I did you know get
time to like hang out with them when I
was in Mexico last year and they just
like have such mutual respect for one
another and I shouldn't say Brad Falchuk
without a shirt on hot good shot
it's very good stuff yeah look I will
send quite a pouch of the day that I
died because I think she's the most
misunderstood woman in America
totally and you know I'm not even
America in the world but I'm loving that
she's doing this press right now because
of the politician because we're getting
just like such a cute interesting
factoids from her right she's like the
type of celebrity where they keep so
like so much to themselves and are very
private that when they do press like
you're always shocked they're like how
kind of funny they are like what you
would think of when is pouch are just
based on what the media says matter is
like she's stuck up yeah and then you
like see an interview with her and she's
[ __ ] funny she's funny she's calling
the kids dicks yeah I love her love Stan
ship a hundred percent I'm so excited
for the politician me too then plot back
on my TV screen like Thank You ripple
threat Ben hi a witness pass for a bride
mousetrap yeah wait Jackie I was
watching on Glee last night and I called
Margo cuz I had a call if you try and
think of like Polly coming out now like
who would play you been pot would play
Kurt or maybe Darren Criss but one of
the Darren Criss I disagreed with the
Kurt like better than client would be on
the show but I make time but there's not
a character necessarily for him right
now okay but who do you think would be
on like the modern-day clay oh well they
were all like up-and-comer nobody yeah I
don't even know like the young people
anything about honestly don't Cameron oh
yeah me as if to say she put out two new
songs that's Nathan they're terrible
what yeah you don't like them yeah and I
like everybody like everybody on the
place needed her will Instagram for this
I know she was so sad when people like
takes a dramatic like measures and like
I love her instruments just like you
know that I feel like people who have
like really great voices have this
problem it's like it's like Lea Michele
too like they have a mozi but like it's
hard for them to like write a good pop
song because all they can do is bail and
you know what I thought been pot was
gonna have that problem like when you
come from the stage the theater you more
often than not like can transition to
like pop music or just like mainstream
like albums and I thought Ben Platt was
gonna fall under that curse but he's has
superseded every single one of my
expectant agree more by the way yeah oh
good I agree with you like Nichelle's
music isn't not it like that song one of
them is good but the album really wasn't
it yes uh people are saying that kami
Mendes and I guess Riverdale has that
musical aspect no I want people AJ app'
for sure yeah no for sure
first up with not his red hair I don't
see it for um I guess I see it like two
teens he's like what's his name Jenner
what's his Blake Jenner that's who he
would be he spin Oh actually my grad
like that call thank you no he's not fit
he's got Ben Blake Jenner who's fin
finish someone like kind of nerdy
looking who's like Noah Centennial no no
who's like not really comfortable in
their own skin and like Jonah doesn't
know that there's like the hot
quarterback you know Jacob oh lordy yeah
oh my god I think it's saying I bet you
it's not shout out well most celebrities
actually can sing that's why they always
like because they all I grew up like
doing theater like if you're an actor
like you were a theater kid you know so
that's why like I was just watching
something where they were singing and I
was like are you kidding me oh oh um
tall girl when they're sitting at the
piano oh god I can't with that but
that's what it is it's like every kid
who like grew up dancing acting like
they also say yeah that's why I like
every now and then they'll sing you're
like that's like what is pouch or like
when she started singing on Glee people
thought it was fake so no she grew up
acting lets you go up to the theater she
probably never sitting yeah and she sang
on Country Strong right and I do feel
like most people can carry a tune and
then there is just like a select few who
can't and Margo and I are in that
category actually Margo doesn't really
let on that she has like a half-decent
voice and she refuses to sing for me
it's so annoying
and I said for my birthday all I wanted
to sing for me and she's she's been out
of the cake and sing just sing like two
lines no please no she's actually not
terrible and the fact that she doesn't
want to sing makes me think that she
actually is holding back no no I can't I
I'm not holding back and you have heard
me sing I always had solos in school
yeah but like there's a reason why you
got them yeah that beautiful voice yes
sing like yeah sure please snitch no
three is ignoring us
two one no it's not having some of this
yeah okay next story um a little airline
drama United Airlines flight diverted
after woman gets stuck in the bathroom
not to find it all this is my worst
nightmare
mm-hmm a United Airlines flight was
diverted Wednesday evening due to a
passenger getting stuck in the bathroom
CBS San Francisco reports United
Airlines flight 1554 was heading to San
Francisco International Airport from
Washington DC but was diverted to Denver
according to CBS Denver dia officials
said the Denver fire department was
called around 7:00 p.m. to get her out a
passenger told CBS 5 firefighters and
mechanic got on board and freed the
woman who was embarrassed by other but
otherwise unharmed no one was injured as
passengers on the flight said the woman
was stuck for about an hour that's
mortifying music Jordan Rogers lol how
do you get stuck on a toilet on a plane
I guess the door jammed oh my god we got
it open um and like how do you get
people to realize that your stuff maybe
have something so loud oh there's like
you know there's a service button in the
elevator like when you're sitting on
your seat you want to drink you could
press the service but it makes it a
little ding there's one in the bathroom
but in the elevator sorry button in the
toilet I in the bathroom oh my god um
but I just also want to say because I've
been traveling a lot like I've really
been experienced I really feel like I'm
the points girl like I'm really
experiencing like different types of
planes and me and Margo flew Air Canada
on the way home from Vancouver and it
was like a brand new plane and the
bathroom it was the nicest bathroom I've
ever seen in my life first of all it was
huge like I could have done a cartwheel
there was a window in it like I was just
like it was so bright that a facial mist
and moisturizer like it was so premium
Air Canada I've only flown one other
time
was i booked it as a regular air canada
flight but it ends up being Air Canada
Rouge which is like their budget airline
and I kind of liked it but it's like has
the worst reputation it was just like a
little old well but this is my first
time flying real ever Air Canada and it
is such a premium airline I'm happy to
hear that yeah I wish I could take it
within the states No did you love it
Margot's it usually Margot sits in coach
because I'm flying her out of my own
expense
but it was a long six-hour flight and I
flew her first class and it was my
first-ever filet pass and a flat
experience and it was just like I
understand why people go places now no
no it was like a litter she wouldn't go
to sleep like we like she kept do you
see this what he was so cute like Livia
I was watching TV I'm have a drink I
thought about it it was like an 8:00
a.m. flight up okay and you didn't want
to forget any yeah I did like she was I
was like watching like my iPad like
lying down and she's like and honestly I
was with her like I was so impressed
like it was literally the most Luntz
experience ever
yeah it was so comfortable like why
would you ever get up no like we were
looking at each other we're like we
don't want to land yeah that's the best
feeling in the world it never happened
never no it doesn't put like that the
flight isn't long enough look I'm a gel
to Stan and I would fly in these Air
Canada flatbeds over Delta anytime wow
that's a big statement okay we ready for
a fifth and final story a little
business yes yeah but the business is
brought to you by one of our favorite
business is Thursday boots Jackie's
waiting for Thursday boots today and I
freaking love them you guys how cute are
these bad boy we have spoken out to
spread a couple times
they're so premium for the start of fall
we received a few of the new releases
from our friends at Thursday boots
they're an NYC based startup that
designs are really really comfortable
high-quality boots and sells them at a
very accessible direct-to-consumer price
their boots are handcrafted in the same
North American and European facilities
as brands that charge two to four times
the price but Thursday can use higher
quality materials and still sell them at
a lower price because they don't have to
deal with markups and wholesalers they
sell them right to you great quality
super cute styles tons of different
types of variations I got an over the
knee pair and also those pair that
you're wearing in shiny black because I
was gonna get those on this saw that you
got them and I didn't like at the same
ones
of course we love all the big brand
names but there see boots are designed
for people who understand quality
appreciate value and want a
great-looking pair of boots that will
last seasons without breaking the bank
vogue actually ranked them among the
best fall boots for under $200 ooh whoa
Madonna hello and if you're looking for
the best every day the Chelsea boot you
should check out their duchess made
whether sales swayed you don't have to
live life in fear of wearing your
favorite pair of boots on a rainy day
and the padded footbed makes them a
pleasure to stand in all day long that's
all so I always think I have flat feet
because when I'm standing for so long
I'm like oh I have flat feet my feet are
broken but no it's I'm not wearing there
I choose because I'm not worried about
Thursday boots Thursday boots believes
in year-round honest prices so while
they don't do sales or discounts they're
giving our listeners free two-day
shipping on their first order and always
offer returns and exchanges so you have
nothing to lose trying out a few pairs
go to Thursday Boots calm / toast and
you can have a pair on your doorstep
before next Thursday that's a Thursday
boots th urs da YB o OTS dot-com / toast
for free two day shipping
returns and exchanges included check it
out sign on and look [ __ ] fresh to
death fresh to death you guys it's it's
a Thursday on Friday and as we've
already discussed Thursday is actually
the best day of the week so check so
feed them final story a little business
a little data news because door - hack
leaks data of 4.9 million customers and
restaurants seamless would never meal
delivery service Jordache said on
Thursday there was a data breach and
information related to four point nine
million customers delivery executives
and restaurants may have been leaked the
data was accessed by an unauthorized
third-party service provider on May 4th
and that's a long time and this is so
bad for door - because you I don't know
why I like when Hoover had their huge
data breach it's like people had been
using uber for years like they were so
reliant on it like honestly didn't care
door - she's like this brand new company
like I know loyalty to door - shouldn't
even downloading yeah now I certainly
know I'm just going to - yeah yeah gotta
get the door I'm - you know this is just
really bad time because they were really
like on their way out they're doing cool
marketing they're doing cool
partnerships drying I had yet to UM
download it yet but the day that I
wanted a Burger King impossible Walker
like I was gonna hit up door - maybe now
I'll just go get it also in news that
I'm shot that you didn't um pick as the
biz news me
Donald is launching a plant-based beef
patty they set up BLT yes and it doesn't
Sam for pretty little thing huh no I
mean I mean um that's just McDonald's it
was a little bit it's time I'm actually
shocked that burger didn't beat them to
it
right and now I'm glad because I do love
McDonald's but there's actually nothing
I can eat there so I don't know why I'm
always there mix up some eats it like
makes it so convenient and so easy to
eat in New York no I literally had a
pretender loss I can get his fries in a
McFlurry and like there's something
about the transition from the fry taste
to the McFlurry taste that's not right
Oh transition is not right that's so
interesting that you say that because I
actually did have McDonald's for dinner
last night which I'm mortified to admit
but let me whenever I [ __ ] love
McDonald's and no one can make me think
otherwise
and I got chicken nuggets and fries and
I was thinking like the transition from
going to the crunchy chicken are game to
the salty french fry was so perfect and
every time I took a bite of a French I
was like oh my god now I really want to
chicken nugget and then I should go buy
the chicken I was like holy [ __ ] I need
a french fry like like this probably
something in it that's like nicotine can
I go balance yeah yeah where they just
makes you crazy Jackie I was actually
thinking so much about like my taste
buds at the time it's so interesting
that you just said that because I was
thinking I'm like oh my god it's making
me want the fries yeah that's how I feel
when I like have a frien I'm like well
now I need a diet coke right where a
pretzel like I have that sort of like
song-and-dance yeah the drink that I'm
drinking but I'm just saying like having
the fries does not make me want to
McFlurry or vice versa
also where you can hide personal like
once I take that bite it of a McFlurry I
cannot go back to fry hope I can no I
like transitional later I was at brunch
the other day and I was eating my um my
salt in my tuna wrap and Rebecca had
pancakes and I could not take a bite of
her pancakes until I was done with my
wrap daddy hid afraid you can't go from
pancakes move and all different yeah
I've been going from like entree to
dessert like I can go entree dessert
back to dessert but it's like entree to
dessert back to entree yeah but like I'm
the type of person it's like if I have a
salad and someone across from me has
french fries and like I eat a French I'm
never going back to the salad that I
agree with
I can salad enfranchise actually one
thing actually you know what I mean I
was talking about like something better
yeah yeah I agree with that but no I
can't go from sweet back to back to
savory and that's just my cross to bear
yeah and so I'm just gonna
have it list with that yes yeah that's
rough yeah it's it's tough so what are
your weekend puns watching politician
catching up with my snatchler and
relaxing really I had such a relaxing
weekend last weekend and I look forward
to doing it again we have a lot of plans
this weekend look just like she's always
hanging out with her friend that I just
like to admit it's like friends plans
yeah friends plans because one of my
friends is moving oh yeah for you guys
oh right should we have a bunch of
things going on so it's like it's a
short pain for like long-term gains for
us for you miss you for the weekend but
we get you further with bullets
we will live everyone I hope you have a
great safe weekend okay flight class you
want to tell them about the guests you
have on Monday
oh yes Monday we have Andy Grammer which
I'm really excited about I'm so sad that
you guys are going to his concert
tomorrow I'm missing it yes I have to go
on the trip but uh he'll be getting a
taste of it on Monday I'm so excited
iced an Andy Grammer so much he'll be
here on Monday June with any other
guests next week that we know about yet
no no not at the moment now that
anything can happen
oh we had some we had someone but it's
it's be it still happened don't tell me
yet still happening but he just didn't
graduate that we planned right okay I
wish that that yes it happened tours
will be so excited and so will the sewol
the toasters I can't say the other word
no okay it's okay love them make a wish
I hope that this guy's comes on I hope
that everyone has a great safe and fun
weekend yeah and have a happy brush
anniversary Shanna starts oh my god a
Sunday so I'll be back Sunday for Russia
shun a Sunday night my adult Monday we
usually wouldn't do a show but because
this guest could only do it we're gonna
work one day on Monday and then go to
shul all like good Jews and Monday night
so are we doing a show Tuesday new year
new me yeah okay okay we're doing Monday
yeah my nice a big day yeah there's only
one hour like we can go to all it's fine
oh my god so we'll see you guys next
year oh yeah happy Rosh Hashanah show
not to that octave of lashena hubbub a
yerushalayim real Hashem love you guys
so much have a great day thank you for
listening to the morning show so
millennial morning show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching on
YouTube please subscribe give this video
a thumbs up leave a nice comment we're
also available as a podcast which if
you're listening to us as a podcast you
already know we're available on Spotify
iTunes
your Public Radio iHeartRadio anyway if
you listen to podcast so feel free to
subscribe to us anywhere you see fit
leave a review 5 stars you know what to
do we love you tickets available to my
tour at girl no job comment hitting up
la San Diego San Francisco mill walking
lease this month
love you and I guessed isn't Kim so fun
they all think it's Kim um guys that's
really sweet that you like thanks so
much of us and that's it's just sweet
that's all I could say but it's not but
it's still really good it really good
it's not him
bye
you